I would ask you about a I think it was a
bus drive train trip you took 20 years
passed yeah a bus trip across the
southern states somewhere where I saw
something very similar to what we see on
our billboards in a field somewhere in
the south which stuck in my mind for
like ten years and I didn't he you know
write it down but I knew it was horrible
enough an outrageous enough to be the
seed of a story and I got the idea that
a mother put it there and and then the
character of Mildred just popped out so
this was ten years past or when you
started writing started writing eight
years ago I mean started and finished it
eight years ago and then has it been
gestating since then or did you have to
put it down before you had um it was
kind of like I always write a thing and
then just don't really I'm kind of too
lazy to do anything about it for a few
years
unless Graham
so just left it in an in a not even in a
drawer you know and on the floor so at
least it would you know and but then we
went back to it I guess five years ago
and and said we should do it and then
sent it straight to Frances and then
sent it to Sam so what was right about
the timing in terms of the way in which
you could make the movie the
independence that you would have
producing and direction it why was that
time right and what were the important
things that's a producer that you wanted
to make sure your filmmaker had the
timing is partly about how often Martin
will make a film and that doesn't happen
as often as we might all like but the
script was written and I read it before
we made Seven Psychopaths which we shot
here in Los Angeles I think as a
producer with talent like Martin what
you're trying to do is to just set up
the very best safest environment to
enable him to do his best work with the
actors so we made this with Fox who
distribute worldwide and film four in
the UK but the structure of it was such
that Martin had the authority as a
filmmaker to do what was right for the
film to make his very best film
I mean it was set up that way and
everyone was very supportive of that
process when you were writing a movie
like this you're writing specifically
for Francis and writing specifically for
Sam yep
what happens if they're not interested
how do you I mean that's a serious
question
obviously they were huge you completely
screwed yeah you are but luckily they
know a good thing when they see one so
no but you would like I can't imagine
anyone else in in those two parts um you
know because they're the best of the
generation so so it it you know you
could probably do do something but it
you know it wouldn't be good so luckily
luckily I didn't have to cross that
bridge one of the things that the film
is very careful about I suspected it is
in working with your actors about tone
and about sentimentality and whether or
not these actors are gonna cinema
sentimentalize the characters that they
are playing what were the conversations
that you had with Sam about playing the
character not judging the character at
the same time I think it's always pretty
easy when we talk about it you know it's
it's never like a big deal we just kind
of like yeah we adjust things here and
there we'll read it out loud you and I
usually get together and read out loud
we but but we we know never to
sentimentalize or patronize the
characters it's just part part in our
DNA I guess especially if it's a
working-class character because that's
sort of our backgrounds - to a big
degree in France is - so that would
never really come into play basically
it's just about finding the truth of a
character if you go for the truth then
those issues don't really come into play
where do you find the truth of Dixon and
where do you imagine what do you imagine
has brought him to where he is at the
beginning of this story you know in
retrospect I think he was probably
beaten by his father or something I
don't know
I mean I didn't really think about that
but now I sometimes but in his
relationship with his mother is very odd
normal to me
normally sure and it kind of Hamlet way
but yeah
Coriolanus way anyway so he hires way
Irish way exactly yeah but yeah he's
he's a complicated guys is it definitely
an interesting character to play I mean
it's a great part that right that Martin
wrote for me so it's a great part and
how do you cast the city I mean how do
you because you have to find a city that
is going to make meet the demands of the
script that is gonna feel as if it's an
authentic city where did you look and
where did you find your epic it's asipi
for a second worried honestly we weren't
it's strange because you live in London
where I do and I don't know the United
States so well particularly the middle
bits so you have this map of States and
tax credits and things like that what's
what's clear is that all the ambitions
if you put people together like sam and
fran and martin and woody that the reach
for everything that everyone wants to do
is so much bigger than a budget a normal
budgets gonna give you and yet you don't
want a tearing budget that gives you all
the pressures and but encourages
blandness so you look for tax credit
states in this version martin was on on
tour almost through various tax credit
States it was mississippi one stage
north carolina offered us ultimately a
town of silver which the one street town
it's featured in the film beautiful
place in real life what was important I
think to Martin and the designer was the
relationship between the police station
and the advertising agency and that one
street told that story so Martin can
tell more about that yeah it was there
to find stuff not iconic small town in
the south and some place that felt like
it could be a character in the film not
as much as you know Bruges was but it
but ii feel like thinking that the town
had its own personality to a degree but
the proximity of one side to the other
was quite important and to find a place
that we could use as a police station
and literally for that two-minute shot
we want
to find a place where a character could
walk from one side to the other
upstairs throw something out all of that
was for in the forefront of their minds
when we picked the town the ending feels
totally perfect and yet it's an ending
that audiences who are conditioned to
tidy endings wouldn't feel comfortable
with with that ending essential did you
ever fluctuate was that always the way
that it had to be it was always that way
in the script we there are there are
almost a couple of false endings before
that and there was a time when we kind
of went back and forth a little bit
about what would be the coolest or the
most cinematic way to end it but I kind
of I mean I love the ambiguity of that
ending and I love that it's not about
vigilantism in in those final moments
when it could be like one minute before
that so so and I and even though it's
kind of messy and a little strange and
ends abruptly I like that in a film I
like that and I like that it's not a
case that's wrapped up because I think
you can review a film that ends like
this you know more than once but if it's
if it's something that's if it's a
procedural if they so who done it then
you know and it's like it doesn't
exactly yeah so that the audience if
done it they the satisfaction is
figuring out or seen who's done it as
opposed to who didn't do it I mean it's
a totally different question yes yes
because this film becomes more about how
are these people changing you know and
and is there hope for people who begin a
story so angrily and so and haven't
having made like such horrible choices
and brutish choices is there room for
hope and that became the story instead
of you know I mean once what he does
what he does in the middle of the film
it becomes not about solving a case it
becomes is there hope to be found with
these people
Martin Sam Grimm thank you so much for
thank you